les chéris allez-y puisqu'il paraît que
c'est un grand danseur celui-ci méritait
ce que voulait guy môquet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi j'avais su que j'avais des problèmes
digestifs a mis à mal et le ghana voisin
de chatchouk non mais ça y est on dirait
qu'il a dit remonté c'est ce que les
cantons ont clos de régler ton au dessus
d'eux en mariage était comme ça ils en
commun à toute épreuve ou danser comme
ça je sais pas mais c'est qu'elle est
dans le regard
vous êtes allé passer chez un opticien
[Rires]
je vais demander aux téléspectatrices
voilà et aux téléspectateurs de eb nous
regardent fait juste vous avez fait et
vont regarder la caméra comme cibles par
des kényans les est d'accord et on va
maintenant l'heure est au centre et la
culture
vous avez péché
attendez donc ça ça regard sensuel
quelque chose est sûre surtout qu'on
cherche le numéro de la police
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]